quando mi chiedono che lavoro faccio
sempre un po di difficoltà non so mai
viene cosa rispondere
e il motivo è che non faccio una cosa
sola ma ne faccio molte forse il motivo
è che il mio lavoro abbraccia tante
discipline include la matematica
medicina la biologia la statistica la
fisica informatica e poi anche perché il
lavoro che faccio cerca di rispondere a
delle domande che non sono proprio
domande facili e lo sa quando mi fanno
questa domanda la prende alla larga
magari siamo a cena inizia a dire mi mi
occupo di capire cosa c'è nelle cellule
umane
mi occupo di capire cos'è che distingue
cellula da cellula cos'è il genoma e di
fatto quello che davvero dovrei dire è
che studio il genoma delle cellule
tumorali e spesso mi sono sentita un po
come ted come un pesce in una boccia
così io magari spesso anche come un
pesce fuor d'acqua
in realtà quello che faccio ve lo spiego
con una scena astratta
immaginate un paziente che ha saputo di
avere un tumore e che si era accade al
proprio medico
mi vengono fatti degli esami dei test di
vario tipo e poi dopo qualche settimana
o magari anche qualche giorno gli viene
prescritto un trattamento che uccide
tutte le sue cellule tumorali ed intuito
il tumore sparisce
sembrava un pensiero così semplice ma
anche così se di magia sembra quasi
un'utopia
eppure questo è quello che noi cerchiamo
di fare questo è quello che noi
chiamiamo la medicina di precisione
cioè quella disciplina che cerca di
identificare il farmaco per un paziente
sulla base del dna che c'è nelle sue
cellule tumorali e il dna dell'individuo
e che viene dato nel momento giusto e
nella dose giusta
questa è la medicina di precisione
quella per la quale noi lavoriamo ora
a scuola ci hanno insegnato che il dna è
il depositario delle nostre
caratteristiche
nel nostro dna c'è scritto stimo castani
biondi rossi se siamo alti se siamo un
po bassi come se da adulti possiamo
digerire il latte se siamo in grado di
tollerare bene la birra ci sono un sacco
di cose scritte nel nostro dna
in ciascuna delle 37 milioni di milioni
di cellule che compongono il nostro
corpo c'è una copia di dna e se noi se
rotoliamo il dna che è sempre molto
compatto e lungo m m tipo così un passo
mio passo
questo è il mio dna se vuoi lo confronto
con il vostro dna è quasi tutto identico
tranne in un centimetro da piccola
piccola percentuale e la cosa bella è
che questo cm che di fatto il fatto di
tante unità sparse ci rende tutti
diversi uno dall'altro ci rende unici
il dna di fatto è anche molto
organizzato non solo nella struttura ma
anche nella sua linearità sono tre
miliardi più di 3 miliardi di lettere
perfettamente ordinate e noi possiamo
pensarlo come un libro con tantissime
parole ovviamente tante pagine e tutto
questo è vero per tutte le nostre 37
milioni di milioni di cellule sane ed è
anche vero di fatto per le cellule
tumorali
solo che nelle cellule tumorali ci sono
degli errori degli organi tipografici
per esempio una lettera sparisce una
lettera viene ribaltata una parola
intera sparisce oppure magari un'intera
frase invece che essere stampata una
sola volta nelle nostre cellule malate o
nelle cellule tumorali è stampata 57 10
volte e questo è quello che noi dobbiamo
capire noi ricercatori dobbiamo trovare
tutte queste errori tipografici che
chiamiamo mutazioni e dobbiamo
identificare quali sono quelle
fondamentali cioè quali sono questi
errori che rendono la cellula tumorale
in grado di prendere il sopravvento
sulle cellule che ci sono intorno e poi
magari se riusciamo a fare ancora di più
e meglio per esempio se riusciamo a
capire da quante queste cellule tumorali
sono nel corpo da dove vengono e dove
vanno che intenzioni hanno
se riusciamo a capire queste cose
abbiamo delle chance in più per
combatterle è quindi in una frase quello
che dobbiamo fare è trasformare i loro
punti di forza del loro tallone
d'achille questo il nostro lavoro
ora di fatto io personalmente sono
arrivato a quasi 30 anni senza sapere
molto sul dna non molto di più di quello
che sapete tutti voi ho studiato fisica
all'università di trento e fisica con la
disciplina bellissima che studia i
fenomeni naturali e li descrive oli
spiega con delle equazioni e quindi ho
macinato equazioni i numeri conti per
anni e poi ancora studiato altri
algoritmi mentre ho fatto il dottorato
in informatica altri modi per analizzare
i dati per capire per predire e un certo
punto mi sono trovato ad avere
l'occasione di andare a lavorare alla
scuola di medicina di harvard che si
trova a boston
eljero unica fisica in un intero
dipartimento di patologia molecolare e
mi ricordo esattamente il giorno in cui
un ricercatore molto bravo
si è seduto di fronte a me e mi ha
spiegato guardandomi dritta negli occhi
che cos'era una mutazione
io sono stato attento ovviamente ho
cercato di capire e poi dopo un po ho
iniziato a capire che forse quello che
avevo imparato le equazioni conti numeri
potevano essere utili ho iniziato a
guardarmi intorno e ho capito che lì
c'erano tante altre persone come me
tante persone che venivano da discipline
diverse c'era molta contaminazione
discipline la cosa bella è che tutti
cercavamo di rispondere alle stesse
domande
e poi queste persone erano molto
combattive e molto determinate
e ho iniziato a sentirmi non più un
pesce fuor d'acqua e e poi sono andata
cornelli a new york all'università e lì
per la prima volta ho condotto un gruppo
di ricerca ed ero proprio al crocevia
tra la medicina l'informatica e la
biologia e il mio bagaglio di equazioni
ha iniziato essere davvero utile poi in
questi anni
erano gli anni primi grandi 2000 è
successa una cosa molto importante per
la scienza ha preso piede una
rivoluzione tecnologica galattica mi
viene da dire quella che ci ha portato a
utilizzare le tecniche del
sequenziamento della nostra routine e
qui vediamo un video era come all'inizio
era come poter guardare dall'alto vie
case poi grazie al sequenziamento
abbiamo potuto entrare quasi nelle
dispense contare tutti i chicchi di riso
che ci sono in un contenitore in una
dispensa in una cucina e non solo
contarli ma anche guardare se sono
simili tra loro
guardare se qualcuno ha qualche
striatura un po diversa come in questa
immagine
questa è la rivoluzione che
sequenziamento ha portato con sé ci ha
consentito di guardare la più piccola
unità del dna in tutta la sua precisione
enorme enorme trasformazione perché
ovviamente se noi applichiamo questa
tecnica alle cellule tumorali possiamo
imparare un sacco di cose e così
praticamente in questo percorso un po
eterogeneo dove ero davvero tra persone
molto diverse tra di loro ho capito che
la mia fortuna era stata avere le mie
quazzo ni essere arrivata nel posto
giusto con le persone giuste nel momento
giusto e con la tecnologia che davvero
giocava a nostro favore
bene con con tutti questi mezzi in mano
possiamo iniziare a rispondere ad alcune
delle domande che ha accennato prima è
un po come il nostro amore come
trasformare la realtà l'esperienza
queste montagne bellissime che vediamo
in una cartina la cartina di fatto è la
codifica di tutto quello che c'è nelle
montagne ci sono le altitudini ci sono i
nomi ci sono le curve di livello che
danno un sacco di informazione e la
sintesi di quello che vediamo è così
similmente con i nostri algoritmi se noi
prendiamo il dna lo guardiamo così come
fosse un cerchio possiamo iniziare a
confrontare nel minimo dettaglio le
cellule tumorali con le cellule sane e
qui a destra c'è quello che possiamo
vedere come l'identikit di un paziente e
ogni piccolo tratto di penna che c'è in
questo identikit di fatto riassume una
montagna o più montagne di dati è
strepitoso tutto questo perché c'è
sequenziamento e possiamo andare a fondo
a fondo a fondo
poi possiamo fare di più possiamo
confrontarli e possiamo studiare la
dinamica possiamo capire da dove queste
cellule sono arrivate e soprattutto dove
vogliono andare e come si trasformano e
all'inizio di quest'anno abbiamo finito
una ricerca con molti collaboratori di
continenti diversi dove per la prima
volta siamo riusciti a vedere come una
cellula come quella di sinistra sotto la
pressione di un farmaco che inizialmente
aiutava il paziente la cellula si
trasforma per non essere più prigioniera
del farmaco vedete come cambiano
cambiata avviato la forma sono entrate
più piccole più compatte sono più dense
sono un po frastagliate e come fosse un
contorsionista che per sfuggire si
camuffa e magari si mette anche un
cappotto maglione una sciarpa qualcosa e
tu non le riconosce più e queste cellule
sono in grado di sfuggire al trattamento
e la bellezza di questa ricerca oltre ad
aver imparato qualcosa di nuovo da un
punto di vista della biologia e che
possiamo capire quando le cellule si
trasformano e aiutare i clinici a
decidere di cambiare il trattamento
questa è la vera bellezza di queste
ricerche ora oltre al bello di fare
qualcosa che può essere utile
il bello del nostro lavoro è che ha un
lavoro creativo perché non ci sono linee
guida non ci sono ricette e
sostanzialmente noi prendiamo moli di
dati enormi terabyte di dati grandi
grandi grandi informato magari come
questi tanti zeri uno è quello che
dobbiamo fare trasformare questa
informazione in qualcosa di utile
dobbiamo trasformare queste informazioni
delle connessioni un po come si faceva
una volta con i centralini telefonici
dove bisognava sapere dove si voleva
andare è un po come cucinare e fare una
torta senza avere la ricetta magari sia
la ricetta e non siano gli ingredienti
non tutti magari c'è scritto quanto
basta e non si sanno le dosi e un po
così nostro lavoro non può essere
fantasiosi creativi bisogna fidarsi dei
collaboratori
bisogna davvero metterci energia e
fantasia davvero fantasia è un po come
essere in prove di volo costanti ogni
giorno ogni settimana ogni mese e ora
siamo in una prova di volo molto grande
e siamo una prova di volo che durerà per
i prossimi cinque anni perché abbiamo
avuto un'idea l'anno scorso che la
comunità europea ha deciso di
finanziarci ed è un'idea che sfrutta il
tallone di achille delle cellule
in questo modo che vi spiego brevemente
ci sono ci sono delle coppie di
mutazioni che sono completamente nocive
per le cellule tumorali
quando accadono contemporaneamente la
cellula non riesce a tollerarle e la
cellula tumorale che l'unica che le
mutazioni muore
allora noi abbiamo pensato scusiamo un
po delle degli algoritmi che abbiamo
imparato in questi anni
e cerchiamo coppie con questa proprietà
coppia di mutazioni che non sono ancora
note le cerchiamo guardando a tappeto su
tutto quello che è stato sequenziato
fino ad adesso ovviamente di pazienti e
poi ogni volta che c'è un paziente nuovo
con una delle due mutazioni diamo il
farmaco contro l'altra
la creiamo e tutte e sole le cellule
tumorali così dovrebbero scomparire
facile come idea forse facile anche
metterla in pratica
e noi pensiamo che questa idea che
abbiamo chiamato spies come le spezie
che si mettono le ricette quando si
vuole dare un po di sapore possa essere
una strada per contribuire alla medicina
e precisione sappiamo siamo molto consci
ed è importante ricordarlo che si tratta
di ricerca ancora siamo lontani da poter
applicare queste cose nella quotidianità
della clinica però la strada è tracciata
siamo sulla giusta via sulla giusta
rotta e quindi noi ci crediamo e
continuiamo in questo modo e in questi
anni ho imparato che non sono più un
pesce fuor d'acqua e sono parte di un
grande acquario e mi sento estremamente
fortunata a fare il lavoro che faccio
grazie
[Applauso]